bis weit nach Mitternacht sind Polizei
und Feuerwehr mit großaufgebotten am
Tatort in Hamburg Alsterdorf Schirmen
das schmucklose Gebäude ab sichern
Spuren es war gegen viertel nach Neun am
Abend als die Hamburger Polizei mehrere
Anrufe erhielt Schüsse seien zu hören
aus dem dreistöckigen Haus dass die
Zeugen Jehovas als Kirche nutzen
zufällig ist eine Spezialeinheit der
Hamburger Polizei für besondere
Einsatzlagen ganz in der Nähe in wenigen
Minuten am Tatort die Polizei ist hier
relativ nahe dabei gewesen und ist dann
recht schnell ins Objekt reingegangen
die Polizeibeamten die dort reingegangen
sind haben dann auch Person angefunden
die möglicherweise die Schusswaffe
schwer verletzt und teilweise auch
tödlich verletzt worden sind die Polizei
sperrt den Tatort am Abend weiträumig ab
warnt die Bevölkerung in der Umgebung
über die Katastrophen waren App und über
die Medien Anwohner sollen nicht ins
Freie gehen während Verletzte und Tote
in Rettungswagen versorgt und
weggebracht werden verdichten sich die
Hinweise dass der Täter für den Toten
sein könnte ein augenzeuger hat
möglicherweise sogar den mutmaßlichen
Täter mit dem Handy gefilmt als er
Schüsse abfeuerte Täter ist irgendwann
ins Gebäude reingegangen durch das
Fenster was er sich zuvor verschossen
hat und dann gab es ganz lange keine
Schüsse auch als der Titel drin war
nur als die Polizei da war circa vier
Minuten danach gab es nur noch einen
einzigen Schuss als die Einsatzkräfte
die Treppe hoch ins Obergeschoss
stürmten fanden sie dort einen leblosen
Mann mutmaßlich der Schütze die Polizei
geht von einer Selbsttötung aus die
Beamten selbst hatten keinen Schuss
abgegeben wir haben bislang keine
Hinweise auf flüchtende Täter wir müssen
jetzt hier die Auswertungen am Tatort
erstmal durchführen im Moment haben wir
noch keine Hinweise auf die
Zusammensetzung der Opfer wir wissen nur
dass mehrere Personen hier verstorben
sind mehrere Person verletzt sind diese
in Krankenhäuser gebracht worden darüber
hinaus geht jetzt die Tatort arbeiten
muss nach der Tat durchsuchen erst
entschärfer die räum danach gefährlichen
Gegenständen dann können Ermittler der
Mordkommission das Gebäude betreten der
Eingang wird abgeschirmt um das
Geschehen vor Kameras und Blicken zu
schützen die Anwohner von Hamburg
Alsterdorf ungläubig und schockiert
konnte mir nicht vorstellen dass ich
sowas mal leben würde da wo ich wohne
das sowas hier passiert in der Borsteler
Chaussee und nun ja für mich schon
ziemlich krasse Situation die
Hintergründe der Tat sind nach Angaben
der Ermittler noch völlig unklar Ralf
Zimmermann von Siefert ist jetzt für uns
aus Hamburg zugeschaltet schönen guten
Morgen hier aus Berlin zu der Tat im
Moment bekannt
also bekannt ist ich habe gerade noch
mal mit der Polizei gesprochen dass es
sich in der Tat um mindestens sechs
Todesopfer handelt
mehrere Schwerverletzte auch sind wohl
auch einige oder möglicherweise einzelne
Personen so schwer verletzt dass dort
auch noch Todesgefahr besteht und
zusätzlich zu diesen sechs bestätigten
Toten gibt es auch einen toten Täter
vermutlich ist das ein Einzeltäter der
gestern um 21 Uhr etwa in dieses Gebäude
hinter mir eingedrungen ist und dort
wild um sich geschossen hat und dann
eben diese Menschen getötet bzw schwer
verletzt hat als die Polizei eintraf um
kurz nach 9 viertel nach Neun wohl das
ging relativ schnell weil einer Einheit
gerade in der Nähe war hat es einen
einzelnen Schuss noch im Obergeschoss
des Hauses gegeben und das war
möglicherweise dann die Selbsttötung des
Täters das alles ist noch mit Vorbehalt
zu betrachten die Polizei will heute
Mittag eine Pressekonferenz geben und
dann
näheres noch zum Tatverlauf
möglicherweise dann auch zum Täter
preisgeben weil man im Moment die
Identität jedenfalls noch nicht bekannt
gegeben hat ob die Polizei inzwischen
weiß wie der Täter ist das kann ich im
Moment auch nicht sagen
Ralf Zimmermann von Siefert war das mit
aktuellen Informationen aus Hamburg
vielen Dank dafür